[Applause]
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constance and kisum
and this is the show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our Berlin guest this week is the
host of the Rubin report Dave Rubin
welcome to trigonometry it's good to be
with you guys you know the alliteration
in both of your names means that you
will succeed as podcasters radio people
youtubers whatever it is that we're all
doing those those are perfect names I
think we'll do very well and I'm very
fortunate that my middle name doesn't
begin with a k' because given the
reputation you get for talking about any
of the issues we're going to talk about
you don't want to have three K's in your
name it probably goes without saying
that we're all white supremacists anyway
so let's just let it be well let's get
straight into the white supremacy then
Dave I send you the host of the Rubin
report which of course is how people
will know you but you've you've got your
new book out which is right next to you
behind your left shoulder don't burn
this book we both read it fascinating
stuff just tell everybody a little
better why did you write the book days
yeah well as I mentioned in chapter one
the when I sign a deal for the book
which was a couple of years ago already
I was originally gonna write why I left
the left and that's a title of a Prager
you video that I did a couple years ago
that has something like 20 million views
and you know I've become sort of the
poster child for the people that are
leaving the left the people that are
realizing that leftism as it stands
progressivism democratic socialism
socialism collectivism whatever you want
to call this new postmodern set of ideas
that seems to have infected our
Democratic Party and really worldwide
lefty politics other place that it has
nothing to do with liberalism and I've
gone out of my way for the last couple
years to try to separate those two ideas
and I'm happy to discuss that further
with you guys but basically that was the
book I was gonna write and after a
couple weeks of writing it I was kind of
like you know I've said all this before
and I don't like I don't like the idea
of writing a book that's about things
that I'm against I want to write a book
about things that I'm for so I went back
to the guys at penguin Random House and
I said hey I know we
this deal here but I really rather do
this talk about free thinking talk about
classically liberal principles talk
about why people are so afraid of saying
what they think you know in a time like
right now in 2020 where you know for
America for all her flaws it's it's a
pretty great spectacular free nation it
still is as as our most Western nations
by the way and they immediately said
yeah we want you to do what you want to
do and that's sort of what changed the
book and what's interesting for me right
now is you know we're taping this sort
of beginning of June of 2020 I finished
writing this book in July of 2019 so 11
months ago and then the publishing
process just takes a long time so you
know you have to edit for a while but
basically I stopped touching the book in
terms of editing and everything else in
November of last year it didn't get
released till April of this year and yet
everything that I write about in that
book is exactly what we're all grappling
with right now watching the left go off
the deep end watching the last few
liberals unable to sort of stop it from
happening because they're either being
silenced or logic and reason just
doesn't play to this new lefty crew some
interesting alliances happening on the
right with sort of disaffected lefties
and libertarians and conservatives and
maybe more than anything else that that
good people are just afraid to say what
they think I mean that really is the
driving point of the book and as we
watch you know
JK Rowling get attacked on Twitter in
the last couple days for basically
saying that we should admit that there
are biological sex differences which we
all know or drew brees who had to
apologize for saying all lives matter
which of course all lives matter and
police lives matter and that's not to
say black lives don't matter I mean
things that we all know are true and yet
the mob comes and attacks these people
and that keeps good people silent and I
just don't want good people to be silent
even if you disagree with me which is
what I say at the end of the book you
don't have to agree with the ten or
twelve policy positions that I that I
lay out in the book but I hope you'll
realize that I've thought them through
thoroughly to get there and then if you
do the same if you use logic and reason
and facts and come to different
conclusions so for example abortion is a
big one that I that
I hold a different position than most of
my conservative friends but if you come
to that position honestly and
forthrightly great let's let's live in a
country with people that have different
opinions do you know Dave when I see
your journey and when I was reading the
book and I saw I'm seeing my own we
shared a lot of the same thing so I form
ask former schoolteacher then became a
comedian lefty liberal all the way
through and slowly I've watched my own
side then it degenerate into lunacy when
was the moment for you where you thought
you know what I can't do this anymore
so I lay out three cases in the book or
three moments in the book where I really
saw like the craziness of the left I'll
do one of them for you now because I
think that'll probably get us into a lot
of the things that are happening in
these days so I was on air at the Young
Turks and as you guys know the Young
Turks is a progressive I would say
far-left
socialist YouTube channel I would say
they've gone further in that direction
since I left a couple years ago but I
was on their channel and and remember I
was a Bernie supporter the whole thing
you can find videos I'm supporting
Bernie Sanders who I now know as
basically you know the worst set of
ideas possible well we were on air and
we were critiquing Fox News which is
what almost everyone on the left does
all day long instead of coming up with
their own good ideas they watch Fox News
all day and then they just sort of wait
to find something that they said so that
they can spend hours talking about it
and as I said earlier I didn't want to
write a book about things that I'm
against I want to write things that I'm
for sadly the left seems to always
position itself especially in a day of
Trump
they're always positioning themselves on
whatever it is the reverse of Trump
that's what we're for but that's not a
position that just means you're gonna
take almost any position and by the way
I think that's Trump's greatest gift is
he can get all his opponents to take any
position that he wants if Trump said
open borders tomorrow they'd all be for
a wall so in effect we were watching a
clip on Fox News and there was a guy by
the name of David Webb who was I believe
on Hannity and David happens to be a
black conservative now I say happens to
me because you're not gonna believe this
but I believe black people can hold all
sorts of political opinions including
black conservatives conservatives there
libertarians they're black anarchists
this is a very problematic divert
account idea I know I know it's a little
racism anyway we're watching this clip
of him and you know he's talking about
basic conservative principles and
they're calling him an Uncle Tom and a
grifter and a sellout and all of these
things and what they didn't know my
co-host was that David Webb and I are
friends I had had a show on Sirius XM
radio years before and I was a lefty and
he was on the right but we met in the
hall one day we became friends and I
used to go on his show probably once a
week or so and we would debate and I'd
take the lefty position he take the
righty position and then we go
downstairs we'd have a steak and have
some whiskey and we were good and we did
this for years now I'm watching the
supposing tolerant liberals look at a
black man who happens to think
differently than they think black people
are allowed to think and suddenly they
think that gives them license to call
him all of the worst things in the world
and at that moment because I knew David
I know David and he is a good decent man
who has spent you know the time coming
to his conclusions honestly I looked at
them and I thought wow you guys are the
racist the anti-racists are the racist
and I think we're seeing that explode
into everywhere right now the people who
purport to be the anti-racist are the
ones constantly injecting racism into
society the average person in America
certainly but again in the West
generally is not racist meaning that
they would want different laws for
different people based on race they're
not racist now that doesn't mean you
might not you might have some old
prejudices and we should do our best to
unpack those and expose them of course
but the idea that the system itself is
racist but really what this moment was
about was a clear-cut example of them
attacking a man I know and using his
race against him because he didn't think
the way they wanted him to think and I
thought this is what I'm seeing
proliferate and now we see it virtually
everywhere it's fascinating to me
because I I'm actually a very good
friends with Zoo
who you've had on the show yeah and he
gets the same he gets all the same stuff
but it's interesting one of the things
you always say Dave is Twitter is not
real life and coming very swiftly on to
what seems to be happening in your
country and in ours right now I I'm
starting to disagree with you on that
one I think Twitter has become real life
yeah you know it's funny when I came up
with that phrase that little you know
one-liner right there it was a couple
years ago and when I first tweeted it
out you know I think I added a couple
caveats that we're seeing it leaked into
real life and all that and and by the
way I did videos about five years ago
about how YouTube culture was suddenly
becoming real life too so I actually
agree with your premise I removed it as
my twitter bio because in many ways well
hey I was promoting the book so it's a
book promotion thing on there now but
but also I think you're kind of right
that that social media the things that
happen on YouTube and Twitter and
everything else are now dictating how
our politicians behave and react now a
lot of that obviously you can link
directly to Trump right because he's the
president of Twitter in effect but I
think you see this across the board
regardless of political allegiance
people seem to want to get the most
retweets the most likes it's caught it's
a constant game to one up somebody
destroy somebody own somebody prove
somebody wrong all of those things and
now we're seeing our politicians and in
many ways us the people were behaving
like that so Twitter in and of itself is
not real life in that if Twitter shut
down tomorrow real life would continue
but yes the ideas that proliferate on
Twitter have now affected the organic
lives that we live in in a really
bizarre way and this is one of the
things we wanted to talk to you about
because big tech censorship is something
that I've written a lot about we have
some extensive experiences as a show
dealing with that because you may be
aware of this last year we interviewed a
gender critical feminist who said that
trans women aren't women and YouTube
deleted that video as hate speech which
incites violence against vulnerable
groups they then reinstated it because
we kicked up a big fire
only last week we had a very widely
respected journalist in this country
Peter Hitchens Christopher Hitchens
brother on the show he talked about the
you know the rationale for the lockdown
not being a solid as people are making
it out to be
YouTube shadow bandit and we caught them
red-handed
we caught had had you catch him had to
care the way we called them is basically
you could not find the video in search
on Google or in YouTube and we literally
got our producer to make a video showing
him searching for it you couldn't and
then we again kicked up a big fuss
three days later no acknowledgement from
YouTube no admission of guilt anything
like that video now is available for
people to watch you know let's talk
about big tech censorship because if if
Twitter is now real life and and they
are in charge of controlling our flow of
information this is this is the issue of
the future isn't it in many ways it is
the biggest issue right and I say that
knowing full well that we're in the
midst of worldwide riots and in at this
point what I would say is a supposed
pandemic it's hard to tell what's real
related to the pandemic at this point
although it'll be really interesting to
see if because of all the riots now and
the protests if we suddenly have a spike
on one hand we know the media is gonna
somehow blame the the Republican states
for opening up early and they won't
blame all the people who were you know
protesting this whole time you know
quickly though on on your specific case
well first off it doesn't surprise me
right we know YouTube does these things
all the time but one of the tricks that
they do is they suppress things and then
only days later do they release them but
then at that point a your subscribers
don't see it it already is going to be
suppressed in the algorithm and not show
up in search and everything else so
they're in effects crushing your video
do you have any paper trail of it or
absolute proof you don't because they're
not stupid and that's what they're doing
so first let's not forget also that
twitter has shadow banning in their
Terms of Service
it is in their Terms of Service that
they are allowed to throttle accounts
meaning certain counts can be seen more
certain accounts can be seamless so in
real life if this was if this was a
basketball game or a
cricket game or whatever else if one
team was playing by one set of rules and
the other team was playing by another
set of rules and every time the score
came in one team won and you didn't and
you knew that the rules were fixed that
yet you kept playing there would be
something wrong with you and in many
ways that's what we're all doing so we
know so for example may on my youtube
channel it was the best month we've ever
had in terms of views watch time
monetization the whole thing now I
partly think that's because of good
content and people are home and they're
watching more and we're doing a lot of
relevant stuff and I had some big guests
but I have no evidence that that's
actually the case sometimes they're just
kind of nicer to you I think I think
possibly what happened was you know Joe
Rogan left is leaving YouTube at the end
of the year and moved into Spotify so I
think they were like holy cow we can't
screw over everybody right now and you
know I've been one of their most
outspoken critics so they're kind of
like alright maybe we should you know
release Ruben a little bit and so that
he sees a little more money coming in he
sees his numbers I don't know if that's
true but it but because we're only
dealing with partial information all the
time it's like we're all conspiracy
theorists right at some level so I think
what you're really asking here is well
what do we do about it right like what
do we do about this it is an incredible
thing that we're able to do this on
YouTube right now it's incredible that
we can release these podcasts we can
find ways to get our audiences my
preference is not to regulate big tech I
don't like the idea that you would take
big tech and then take big government
and somehow align them together I don't
think government does virtually anything
well so the idea that government
bureaucrats would be going to the
offices of Google and YouTube to try to
figure out what they're doing with the
algorithm like I just don't think that's
possible
I think the ship has sailed I don't
think government's functional enough I
think these companies are too big now
what Trump did a week or two ago was he
did an executive action which by the way
I don't love executive actions right
because that's not really how we're
supposed to be governed right we're
supposed to be governed meaning that the
legislative branch Congress is supposed
to pass laws the president's just
supposed to sign him but all presidents
do these executive actions and what he
basically said is if you guys are gonna
act as a publisher decide who can be
seen and who can't be seen well then
we're going to remove legal protections
I'm basically okay
with that because that's not regulating
in a traditional sense that's saying
we're removing legal protections so if
you're gonna be messing around you're
gonna be more liable to lawsuits so I'm
basically okay with that
but for guys like us that are free
speech people that wanna exchange ideas
maybe talk to two scary people sometimes
or perceive scary people there's a
danger in that too because you know if
Twitter and YouTube suddenly go oh you
know our our legal protections aren't
here
well then suddenly they may want to be
censoring more things because they're
not gonna want certain conversations on
board so I think we all have to be very
careful what we ask for and I'll just
say one other thing which is I'm a man
of my word and I don't just talk about
these things I actually put them into
action
I started locals calm we're building
digital homes for creators where you own
the video you own the audio you own the
user data you set your rules in your
community and and the company's blowing
up and we're getting tons of people on
there and you guys should be on there
and anyone that wants to own their
future by being on YouTube by being on
Twitter by being on Facebook you're
renting an apartment from a crazy
landlord who's willing to rip up the
lease at any moment you need to own your
stuff and that that's what we're doing
with locals calm so you wouldn't agree
dive as in two types of the left-wing
view which is to come in and break these
monopolies up well why not because
because the idea that the government
well first off I don't think the
government has any right to do that no
one's forcing us to be on google on
youtube on twitter now you can argue
that maybe they've become the new public
utilities right the phone company or the
electric now I think you I think there
is some argument for that but I think
it's I think it's a rather unimaginative
argument you know there's so many
interesting things happening in the
world with decentralization and
blockchain and so many cool ways to get
your stuff out there that yes if Twitter
banned me tomorrow let's say tomorrow
they pulled an Alex Jones on me and they
banned me from Twitter YouTube Facebook
the whole thing with that would that be
awful and and a seeming let's say a
seeming infringement on my rights it
seems like it would be but they still
are basically private companies the idea
that the government
can come in and say oh we're gonna break
you up so that maybe more competition
can arise so that maybe more voices are
in it it's just like I don't think the
government is good at anything I don't
know anything that the government's good
at so why would they be good at this and
also let's not forget you know all the
conservatives that for a year have been
screaming Trump has to regulate he has
to regulate a big tech it's like you
know Trump could lose the election in
November and let's say now you get I
don't I'm not even sure it's gonna be
Biden but let's just say it's Biden and
with Elizabeth Warren as VP something
like that well congratulations you just
married the progressives who would love
to silence all of us with the
regulator's with big tech with
government that is a nightmare scenario
just try to imagine if the government
had more power over big tech and now we
have President Joe Biden or Elizabeth
Warren or something like that or Kamala
Harris or God knows which one of these
clowns they're gonna select but imagine
that and then all the Conservatives were
attacking the president all day long on
Twitter the way that blue check left
these do on Trump all day long you think
they're gonna stand for that they will
boot these people in a second so those
of us that don't like centralized power
even when it feels like we need it most
we have to be wary I mean if you don't
have principles when they're tough to
have you don't have principles but that
all that being said I like that this
argument is being hit in many different
ways so you know Tucker Carlson is more
okay with regulation I've discussed that
with him on a show I'm more of a free
market guy
the Prager you people who are who are
I'm totally aligned with on most things
they're suing they're in an ongoing
lawsuit with YouTube over censorship so
I think you have to hit these companies
in many different ways and I'm not
saying that I'm purely 100 percent right
but I'm putting my money where my mouth
is with my company and we'll see what I
think we need to have is transparency
that's the one issue we don't have at
all at the moment so if we knew what
they were doing if we knew how that I'm
never gonna get them why not you're
never gonna get it because that because
either you have to have the government
force them to be transparent which once
the government's involved it's like
nothing nothing good will come of this
it will it will actually harm their
ability to innovate and do
do what they want to do whether those
things that the things that they want to
do or good or bad is almost irrelevant
at that point but yes would we all like
them to say this is what our algorithm
is and if you talk about these things
you'll be you know exploding in views
and if you talk about these things
you're gonna be depressed they're never
gonna do it I mean I mean the ship has
sailed the idea that they're gonna do
that you know why they also can't do it
because they would completely expose
themselves as publishers not as
platforms which goes directly to what
Trump's executive action was about
because then they would be open up to a
bajillion lawsuits which by the way I
think is why we see these you know
people like Jack who's the CEO of
Twitter Jack Dorsey and Susan Wojcicki
at YouTube you know they're they're
always donating money to lefty causes
and by the way because they're basically
just buying protection because they want
to be thought of as good guys while they
do a lot of shady stuff that's the
simple truth see my concern with and
we're exploring this issue with you Dave
I don't have a fixed position on it Mike
I'm happy to hear it yeah I mean my
concern was something like Google is the
idea that Google is you know just a
private company Google I mean look at
what's happening in the streets of our
countries right now in my mind that is
the product of 50 years of progressive
intersectionality ideology being
indoctrinated into people and university
campuses and and college campuses in
America that has been supported and
enabled and guided by these big tech
companies so the reason people black
people are being shot in the streets of
America right now to some extent is a
product of the big tech companies doing
what they're doing so you know this idea
that it's just a private company doing
business I I don't buy that well that's
why I said I'm completely okay with
hitting this in many different ways so
Prager Prager using the legal means me
using the the means of the market etc
etc and I'm not even making the argument
that they are purely private we know
that these companies have all sorts of
relationships with the government we
know that there are backdoors we've
they've talked about this in Congress
where they can see data through the
backdoor
that's not publicly available but again
I think that my my overriding feeling
this would be okay so let's break up
Google Google has to be seven different
companies those companies will be
regulated in strange ways by the
government but then remember let's say
you guys are somewhat friendly I sense
you guys are somewhat right-leaning so
you're somewhat friendly to either the
Trump administering coma day this is
terrible I probably screwed both you
guys but what I was but all right let's
deal with that quick but when I say
right-leaning at this point what I mean
is you're probably old school liberals I
mean you're probably just decent free
speech people who don't want the
government to do everything that's
become basically a right-leaning
decision I know that sounds scary and a
lot of people freaked out but that just
sadly is the right-left thing is all
screwy anyway but whatever it is that we
all are let's just say people who are
open and want free speech and and some
liberal principles something like that
we just need to be really wary about
what we ask for because imagine giving
the power of big tech and then marrying
it with government if you don't like
who's in charge of the government and
this is what this is the in many ways
the key flaw of all of the lefties the
lefties and then the birdie crew and all
of these people they rail against
government all the time government's
evil politicians or evil corporations or
evil everything's giant and evil and
their answer is oh if we could only give
it more money raise taxes on people make
the state bigger and it's like you know
what I would prefer to do is I think
you're right about some of the things
big government is evil there are there
are problems with central planning above
us I like I like bottom-up growth my
answer would be okay so you starve the
beast you let people keep more of what
they earn I want you guys to keep
absolutely as much money as you earn as
possible and then I'm not a complete
'anarchist or a total libertarian that I
think taxes are theft I think I mean
this would be the classical liberal
position you need some government
unfortunately
to keep the guardrails on society but I
can tell you this I live in California
we have insanely high property taxes and
income tax and everything else there are
potholes all over the street there are
homeless people everywhere Texas Florida
they have no state income taxes they
have a balanced budget we've got massive
deficits so everyone looks at all of
these things backwards and when I say
right-leaning I usually mean decent
human beings it's very much the opposite
and when the industry that we operate
and Dave officialy I am centrist and
Francis is an old-school lefty and
nobody can tell us otherwise if you guys
lose your gig after this you can come
work for me but Dave but we're looking
at society now and I don't know about
you but I'm incredibly worried like we
started off as you intimated before that
the culture war was started off as this
online thing it's now bled into reality
how bad do you think things are at the
moment and do you think it's gonna get
worse yeah well it is gonna get worse
I'll do that part first we have not hit
the bottom of this thing for sure that's
number one we can explore that a little
more in a sec look there was a bunch of
us I would say about 40 or 50 people
maybe even less actually online over the
last five years that were talking about
these issues right Brent weinstein and
ayaan Hirsi Ali and Maajid Nawaz and Sam
Harris and Douglas Murray and and a
series of people that were talking about
all of these things that's really what
put my show on the map that there was
something wrong with leftism and
liberalism was being destroyed I don't
know if you guys are Star Wars guys but
I always make the analogy that the
lefties the progressives basically
executed order 66 on the Liberals they
just decided to assassinate everybody
and now we've got a couple liberals
scattered throughout the galaxy but they
don't have much power and they don't
have to communicate and they don't know
what to do with each other that's that's
sort of the situation we're in right now
now this this idea of intersectionality
of collectivism of post-modernism that
nothing is true anymore and history is
actually just something that was taught
to us by the white man so history is not
even history
in the UK we should be tearing down
monuments to Winston Churchill who
literally stopped the Nazis and we
should be tearing down our monuments
here and all these things we really need
to understand that destroying things is
very easy you guys me everyone watching
this could commit our lives to
destroying the existing world because we
can there's an existing world and an
existing structure
we could see it we can feel it we live
in it and it would be very easy for us
to just spend all our time trying to
destroy it that's what the modern
lefties are doing it is much harder to
rebuild things or to build things from
the ground up we in America have built
something that is so spectacularly
precious and good and decent where
everyone from every corner of the earth
came here made a better life for
themselves nobody comes to America and
stays in America for five years and it's
like I can't do it here I'm going back
nobody leaves nobody ever leaves
everyone that stays it doesn't mean you
get everything you want right but it
means most likely almost without
exception that you will pass a better
life to your children and then their
children and so on then anywhere in the
world this is an incredible experiment
America is just an idea the idea that we
can all come here and figure it out
America is not based on an ethnicity or
religion or anything it's based on
individual rights and the pursuit of
happiness this is a beautiful thing but
the set of ideas now that are bursting
forth that we're gonna have white people
bowing to black people and we're gonna
ban police departments and we're gonna
basically be this lawless state and
meanwhile you know the reaction to that
is what's happening gun sales are
absolutely through the roof almost
everyone I know now is buying a gun yeah
almost everyone I know is buying the gun
people that were always against guns
lefties in California are suddenly
buying guns you know this this is what
the left has wrought we warned them but
will it get worse it absolutely will get
worse because we have an election coming
in November the left didn't accept the
Trump election the first time and then
ran with Russian collusion and Ukraine
and a whole bunch of other stuff so
there's there no way they're gonna
accept the election this time and I do
think Trump's gonna win most likely in a
landslide short of something
crazy but not only that we could have a
bump in in Corona there you know we
don't know like listen to some of the
crazy things coming out of these rioters
they're saying that destroying property
is not violence really you know if
someone came and burned down my house I
would consider that a violent act but
they're literally trying to change the
meaning of words these are not good
people at the top of this thing I think
the average protester and the average
confused young person the road to hell
is paved with good intentions I don't
think they're out there trying to be
evil necessarily I don't think they know
the statistics I don't think they know
the statistics related to police
brutality or related to racial
incidences or any of these things and
the left is really great at manipulating
people's emotions so I think it is
unfortunately going to get worse we
don't have a lot of adults in the room
I'm trying to be one of them but we need
way more people to make well this frame
was hopefully trying at least in this
conversation but this is what I wanted
to explore with you Dave because Lou
Perez from we the Internet's a friend of
ours has been on the show he posted
something the other day saying it's 2020
so silence is violence words of violence
but violence isn't violence yeah he's
right I mean literally they're telling
us violence isn't violent but it's also
silence I mean right so so so silence is
violence because then that means you're
acquiescing to this is the evil system
that's I mean that's just bananas you
might just want to write a rhyme so that
then thus it must be true and good but
this Islands is not violence you know
the idea that words or violence is also
completely crazy it's completely counter
to the First Amendment and anyone that
cares about free speech should
understand that but this this next idea
that violence is not violence that
tearing down monuments that destroying
cop cars literally burning down
buildings looting stores these are not
violent acts well first off you know a
lot of people have been killed in these
riots I think about six black people
including David Doran who is a 77 year
old retired police chief I think you
know so people are being killed so that
would count as violence but again when
someone says attack
property is not violence I wonder if
they would think if someone put their
house to fire while they were in it
would that be a violent act or not now
we all know it's true but the left is
really good about manipulating language
and words and it's it's deeply deeply
dangerous and it's not also the fact
that they're very good at manipulating
words and I've seen it because my
mother's from Venezuela and what they're
exceptionally good at is making you
scared like there are aspects of the
black lives matter movement and you know
that defunding the police and everyone's
good less defund the police I'm like
what do you mean defund the police
that's insanity if you have a crime
problem then would you want war police
or less police now that doesn't mean
that you want an unending police state
that doesn't mean you want you know to
be fearful of the you know be living in
a community where the police are
patrolling all the time and they're just
randomly grabbing people and putting
them in black bags and driving away but
generally we know that when we put more
policing in certain neighborhoods that
things do get cleaned up now that
doesn't mean there aren't some bad
apples this is how you have an honest
discussion about this stuff but the idea
of defund the police in the midst of all
of this
look the simple thing is this anyone
watching this clip this and let's listen
to it a year from now and in a year from
now if Minnesota or Minneapolis has
defunded the police I will bet
everything that it is going to be more
violent and scary and if it isn't it
will only be because people either won't
report things or people will basically
be trapped in their houses or or just a
huge population transfer I mean if
you're if you're just an average decent
person living in Minneapolis right now
and you like rule of law basic law and
order you thought life was pretty decent
before all this would it make sense to
stay in Minneapolis you better get the
hell out of there
so there they're really good at taking
bad ideas and making them sound just and
I think one of the things that
conservatives have have failed at for a
long time is that it it takes more
effort and more intellectual heft to
explain things to say well actually look
at the studies in 2019 only nine
unarmed black men were shot by police
that's infant assimil 19 were shot by
white men now you're gonna have to
really grapple with that and think and
and then what they'll say to you is well
that doesn't matter the facts the facts
of the case don't matter we just feel
America is racist and America was
founded on racism and the rest of it and
again it's very easy to destroy it is
very difficult to create well it's
exactly the same thing that we have in
the UK you know we for we had a massive
Ferrari over a government advisor who
traveled to somewhere to be with his
parents so they could look like a
non-story basically for weeks it was
covered like it was a it was like on
9/11 but that was the level of coverage
Hugh this week we have massive protests
on the streets thousands of people
gathering now it's okay and now he's
fine and like no one is talking about it
the media of just stop talking about it
and lastly not only is it fine now but
we've had we've had New York City
officials one of them I think is like
the deputy health official of New York
City is I think his name's Mark Levine
he said that if there is a spike because
of the protests that it won't be because
of the protests it'll be because of
racism
I mean think how profoundly ridiculous
that is like that's idiocracy on
steroids absolutely on steroids so there
are so many and then that's why to get
to your earlier question about will this
get worse in many ways the entropy of it
the energy of it has to get worse
because it hasn't burned out yet but you
guys might remember on January 1st first
day of the year
I always tweet out a thread about what I
think is gonna happen in the year and I
kind of look back at whether my
predictions over the last couple years
have been right and I've been pretty
good in this game and my feeling was
that intersectionality and all of the
stuff we're talking about right now was
gonna collapse this year because the the
competing interests of it would be too
much to bear in an election year I still
think there is a chance it collapses now
it won't go away quietly and it will be
it will lash out in horribly violent
ways I mean I think they're they're just
beginning to show you how violent they
are this won't be just about blowing up
buildings I mean we're I think we're
gonna see a different level of terror
with them and all sorts of stuff I'm
talking about aunty Fah specifically
like I just don't think we realize what
level they're willing to go to to cause
chaos but what I think is a trump
reelection in November would be another
absolute just foot on on the face of
this thing but but imagine if Trump
loses now this doesn't mean you have to
be the biggest trump supporter in the
world I didn't even vote for Trump I'm
basically okay with Trump and yes what I
like him to tweet a little bit
differently sure we've been everyone's
been through that already but imagine if
Trump loses and then you know again I
don't know the Biden's even gonna be the
nominee but if but if the Democrats who
really stand for nothing but you know
they're all I saw today Chuck Schumer is
bowing and Nancy Pelosi's bowing and the
rest of them all of the worst ideas of
society will be will be empowered in the
scariest possible ways and then when we
when we all joke that the gulag is
coming it won't be a joke well hey man
I'm from Russia so I've been warning
people it's been coming for a long time
yeah you know you talk about on Tifa we
had Andy no on the show last time he was
in London so our view is on under any
illusions about who these people are at
all but I want to talk to you about the
media because you know you had you and
girag and I guess so probably the two
biggest shows on these kind of issues in
the u.s. we are probably the biggest
show in the UK talking about this stuff
and what I see with with the media is
that feelings world that you've been
talking about where if you feel
something's right then then that's fine
that seems to have completely infected
the mainstream media as well to the
point where large sections of the media
in this country the BBC included simply
refused to cover the facts and the bezel
is completely inaccurate the BBC is
complete and utter nonsense ever every
headline at this point that I see from
the baby I thought the BBC run hit
pieces on me where they don't even put
the author's name they literally just
write a piece with uncredited to an
author that that's what cowardice and
and lack of journalistic standards is
happening at the BBC well they're a
great success I hope one day to get to
the level where they get they get the
same [ __ ] for us man yeah
oh boy so i kumite so i listen i truly
hope you guys get there i really it will
be a pleasure that will be a great side
but you i'm sure you guys saw the
headline I'm gonna slightly butcher it
but just in the last couple days there
was a headline in the BBC about the
largely peaceful rallies where what was
it something like only like nineteen
police off when he 77227 well only
twenty-seven police officers injured in
largely peaceful protests and in the
picture you see a horse being attacked
there's an officer on the floor
I mean it's complete chaos and and in my
book by the way I write about you know
there's a chapter on how to spot fake
news and what what we all think I think
what are a lot of people think is that
fake news is just fabrications like it's
just like a completely fake story but
that's not really what the scariest type
of fake news is in many ways fake news
is a headline that doesn't match the
story because you because most people
just look at the headline they don't
read the article or another another
really dangerous type of fake news is
when the media purposely ignores a story
because it doesn't fit their narratives
so if the media had been dealing with
any of the things that we're talking
about honestly here then we wouldn't be
in this situation because if the media
had been saying for the last couple
years you know there really is a problem
at the academic level and there really
are some problems related to how we're
talking about trans issues or racial
issues or everything else but instead
the media ran everywhere in the UK and
here and in most Western places that all
of our societies are evil and racist no
matter how much proof we have that
they're not there are no laws in the UK
that stop anyone from doing anything
based on the color of their skin and if
you guys can point me to a law that says
if you're black or you're a new
immigrant or something like that you
can't do this well then I will gladly
fight that law with you and and by the
way there are no laws in the United
States that stop you from doing
something based on this color of your
skin or your sexuality or your gender or
any of those things but they have lied
to everybody for so long to make it seem
like that's how society operates that
now we wonder why young
people are burning down buildings and
then of course the ultimate irony of
this is that these these buffoon
newscasters who are cheering it on on
CNN and these idiot really awful
celebrities you know Seth Rogen and
Steve Carell and these ridiculous
celebrities who live in multi
multi-million dollar mansions in the
Hollywood Hills with security and gates
and never have to go shopping for
themselves because they have other
people do it at the stores that are
burning down although the store is
burning down aren't even in their
neighborhoods it's like you guys are the
ones you think this is gonna save you
you fools like set throw them they're
gonna burn down your house and it and
there will be those smell of weed will
be all over Los Angeles right but they
will burn down your house because no
matter how much money you give them no
matter how many times you bow to them or
put out your crappy movies you will
still be a rich white guy at the end
seth rogen so you're gonna get what's
coming to you not by my law by their law
so you heard it here first guys dave
rubin doesn't live safe it's a Frogger
movies anyway it's really interesting
what you're saying because there was a
radio show host or somebody who worked
in radio here who got in problems
because he didn't agree with white
privilege he said that he didn't agree
with the concept it's now becoming the
case where if you say that you disagree
with certain political statements you're
done look let's talk about the white
privilege thing for a second first off I
would say that in America there's no
privilege other than American privilege
yes some people are born with money some
people are born poor some people are
born with great physical attributes some
people are born handicapped some people
are born smarter some people aren't that
bright those are all the things that's
the good word I'm gonna give you the
gestalt of life that's just the the mix
of life but all a free society can do is
hey we're gonna give you guys equal laws
some of you are gonna work really hard
some of you are gonna make your luck
some of you are gonna be lazy but but
we're a free society so we have equal
laws for everybody let's pretend that
white privilege was a real thing let's
pretend it was really real now let's now
okay-y privet is real so we're what are
you gonna have to do well that means
you're gonna have to punish white people
now should a 18 year old white kid who's
busted his butt played by the rules
worked hard in school did after
curricular activites did athletics and
everything else should he be punished as
he's trying to get into college should
he be punished and treated differently
based on the color of his skin through
no fault of his own to let in somebody
else my answer to that is no that would
be racist
and by the way Harvard is doing this
right now they didn't want that many
Asian students there so they make it
harder for Asians to get into college
now why would we not now that sounds
like racism right we're taking of people
of a certain race and we're making it
harder for them to come into school why
should we punish Asian people Asian
people whether they're Chinese Japanese
Korean whatever it is they by and large
are at the top of our socio-economic
ladder because they work really hard
they care about education there's the
idea of tiger mom and they care about
family and they thrived in the American
system why would you start punishing
them for that no one gave when a Korean
family moved here in 1950 then anyone
gives them anything no and by the way if
you moved here from Italy or Ireland or
you were a Jewish immigrant or whatever
it might be no one gave you anything you
got here you busted your butt I in my
book I talk about my my two
grandfather's who both fought in World
War two one of them was flying planes
one of them was a mechanic but I
remember my grandma already he died when
I was in second grade but I remember him
telling me when I was probably in first
grade he was handing me like some change
or something and he said that his first
job was for a quarter a quarter an hour
and he grew up in in a bedroom with six
brothers and sisters his father died
when he was 2 years old I mean the
things that the people of before us have
been through and that we're gonna sit
here in 2020 and be willing to throw
that away or to watch just in the last
day you know people in the UK tearing
down statues of people and writing
Winston Churchill was a Nazi the guy who
literally you know helped us defeat
I mean there is no greater hero a flawed
man for sure but in many ways there is
no greater hero of the last 100 years
than than Churchill he's at least in
that in that Parthenon of people so
we've we've done almost everything
backwards and we need people to start
getting braver that's that's the only
answer just for accuracy Dave I'll say
that they put Winston Churchill as a
racist so not quite so bad we know which
was the which was the statue that they
did pull down he was of Edward Colson
who was a Conservative MP and the
slave-owning you know he profited from
the slave trade he built a city where I
went to school Bristol lots of it so I
listen I won't pretend to know more
about him that I do know so I won't
comment on that specifically but you
know we have to remember that all of us
including us right now we are just
people of our time there is there are
things that people in the future will
think of us like we eat meat of how
barbaric we were and and and let's not
forget Barack Obama ran against gay
marriage when he was first running for
election into in 2008 the progressives
of 2045 are going to burn down the Obama
library because he was an anti-gay bigot
that is that is why again this is a
movement of destruction not creation our
founders in America they owned slaves
George Washington owned slaves his half
of the slaves did not get freed till he
died and then Martha his wife actually
kept her half but you know what he was
also the man who led the war for
independence and people wanted him to be
the president and the general leader of
the army and he said no I won't do both
and he voluntarily put his power down
that's an extraordinary thing Thomas
Jefferson owned slaves while writing the
laws that freed the slaves it does not
mean they were perfect people there were
a million Thomas Jefferson wrote about
how he was afraid that if he freed his
slaves and everyone freed their slaves
immediately that it would create this
giant underclass of unemployment and all
of these other things now that doesn't
mean it's right what he did or anything
else but the idea that we're just gonna
burn all of the history as if we're so
great right now like does anyone think
we're really so great right now look
where we're at
look at the things we're debating my
theories or even a bigger issue Dave to
be honest with you I think that's
certainly an issue but there's a much
bigger issue at play here which is
fundamentally you know it's like the guy
who statues they pulled down and threw
into into the water he he was he was a
slave owner but the question is do i i i
come from russia i was born in the
Soviet Union do I get to go and pull
down a Karl Marx statue in London
because I feel strongly about it it's
not bad I ain't gonna be no no not the
beloved Karl Marx ain't very happy about
that one
every group gets to pull down whatever
they want and we get to use just
violence and destroy things because
that's what we don't like is that the
society we want to live in where if I
don't agree with somebody and there's a
statue of them from 300 years ago I get
to go and destroy that what about a
building that was built with that guy's
money do I get to pull down a building
well though I get to kill his great
grandchildren I mean where do we take
this no you're making great points and
let's not forget building burning
buildings doesn't count as violence so I
guess in that case but you're yeah of
course you're making a great point and
this is why we have to fight this crazy
ideology because everyone has a
grievance or a perceived grievance
against someone or something so if we
want everything not to be destroyed then
we better we better start calling this
nonsense out for what it is I mean even
I'm fascinated actually by what's going
on in the UK right now because you guys
there's no evidence that I've heard of
that you guys have any problem with
policing at any level we separating
whatever's going on in America there's
no evidence that you guys have it I'm
watching cops running you're cops I'm
sure you saw through the mob chasing
your cops away I mean the whole thing is
backwards there and again that shows you
that this terrible infection of
postmodernism it's here to destroy the
West it is here to destroy capitalism it
is here to destroy freedom they're doing
it in the name of tolerance but they are
truly the least tolerant people around
who destroys who in the last couple
years remind me guys who in the last
couple years was tearing down a lot of
monuments Isis remember Isis yeah
remember what they were doing in Syria a
lot
monuments went down but the thing that I
always find very interesting Dave is the
left's embrace of communism and in fact
when they graffiti'd Churchill's statue
there was a hammer and a sickle on there
as well
why is it we have suddenly gone back to
one of the worst ideas of the 20th
century it hasn't worked anywhere it
certainly didn't work in Venezuela I saw
it happen with my own eyes why are this
young generation embracing it well
they've been tricked by easy answers
instead of thinking I mean this goes
back to how did this all start well it's
mostly a failure of Education
you know the bad ideas that have been
imported into the West about
collectivism and socialism and communism
the idea that that taking from some and
giving to others just because you feel
like it that that is a admirable
position that's called greed that's
called envy and yet we've been ported
this through Bernie Sanders in many ways
as if this is a good set of ideas Bernie
you've never accomplished anything how
do you get to decide who can keep what
they are and who can't keep with Aaron
and who should get what and what should
be free which we know isn't free and
what minimum wage should be when you've
never run a business III have a small
business here I know a little bit more
about running a business than Bernie
Sanders who's never accomplished
anything I mean that's the truth he's
just an old failed socialist and by the
way they will destroy Bernie one day too
I mean the next level of this thing is
Bernie just failed twice and he backed
Hillary Clinton and now he's backing
Biden so they'll they'll take out Bernie
there's no doubt about that and that'll
be a pretty beautiful day well you've
got a or C coming up so you've got
someone to replace them you'll be fine
no we've got a much worse version of it
a much scarier version of it because
she's better on television and the rest
of it I mean I think she's mostly a
dullard who's just felt you know they
give her ideas and then she tweets them
and it's like every time she tweets
something that sort of sounds smart it's
like who's tweeting this because this
didn't come this didn't come from you
she's just terrible
but why are these ideas proliferating
well look I think you can explain it
this way if you're if you're on the
right like you far-right maniacs a time
if you know the right thing to my soul
anyway if you're on the right what do
you basically believe I'll do this from
an American perspective but I but it'll
very much fall congruently with a UK
perspective if you're on the right you
basically believe in individual rights
that's sort of the core belief and from
an American perspective that means those
rights are granted to you or really
protected by the Constitution of the
United States so everyone should have
the same rights regardless as I said
before a sexuality gender color of their
skin or the rest of it that that's the
core of what being on the right is now
the right doesn't always behave that way
and and you can argue there's more
libertarian versions and more
conservative versions in every those but
that's sort of the core belief of being
on the right that you have rights and
that the government should stay out of
your way is the pretty much the the
underwriting principle on the left
there's no underwriting principle
anymore
other than the state what is the thing
that brings people on the left together
other than they want the state to do
everything it's not individual rights
it's not limited government or some
principle right those things are
principles on the left it's oh the
government is supposed to do stuff well
if you take that to its logical
conclusion where do you end up you end
up with communism or fascism or
socialism or something because that's
where you've outsourced all of the power
to the Machine so this is the irony
these people who think they're in the
resistance are actually the biggest suck
ups to power if you don't want something
to have power don't give it your money
don't give it your rights what they want
to do is they love power that's why
every time you you have a progressive
who's you know they run around with
their blue hair and they seem like
they're for tolerance and decency and
all that but if you scratch them for
just a second what you will always find
is a really nasty authoritarian beneath
that who wants to control you so a great
example I can give on this is on the
right when you talk about wages on the
right basically will say will you let
the market decide if someone wants a job
the person who owns the business could
decide what to pay them and then that
person could decide if they want the job
I think that's basically a pretty sound
principle on the left now
they'll say no $15 minimum wage now who
came up with that Bernie basically came
up with it and how'd he come up with it
well he just thought of a number that he
seemed to think was right he has no
principle to pick that number there's no
economic principle that says that's the
right number and there's by the way
there's no ethical principle that says
the government can force you to do it
either but what happens is he says $15
and then because these people believe
government is inherently good
Rashidah talib who's like a sideshow of
a OC she says no it should be $20 and
it's like well you know he just made up
a number and she made up a higher number
so she must be right and why not $35 she
must be bet today she must be a lot
better you're right because a OC what
was one of her most famous accidentally
poignant lines she said the guy you
don't have to be factually correct you
have to be morally right and that's what
she means you don't have to think things
through you just have to feel and where
do I cuz I don't know where her morals
come from to say you have to be morally
right well okay there's something good
about being morally right but I I don't
think I share the same moral code nor
the most Americans as AOC but I think
you got my point there that then they
get in that's why everything on the left
becomes a race to out government
themselves because there's no unifying
principle other than government so every
time you say the government should do
more it de facto makes you seem like
you're a good person do you think there
might be a part of it as well that
capitalism for a lot of people and
particularly the younger generation dave
has stopped working for them in that
wages have stagnated gap between rich
and poor is increasing for instance in
the UK the chance of owning a house is
from a lot of people or property is
rapidly you know evaporating and a lot
of these kids are going you know what
why should I buy into capitalism if
capitalism gives me nothing right so
first off I mean we should blow up a
couple myths here capitalism has freed
more people and caused more prosperity
than any other system there's the famous
quote I forget who it is I'm going to
slightly butcher it but basically
capitalism is the best of all of the bad
systems capitalism is the chance that
you have to work really hard to build
something good for yourself now that
doesn't
it's gonna work all the time as I said
before and by the way you are right that
we're seeing the rich get richer and the
poor get poorer and what we need in a
you know in a healthy society you do
want the middle class is what you want
strengthen the most so that doesn't mean
that capitalism in and of itself is
perfect because by the way then what
happens is the government gets involved
and then the government is constantly
rejiggering the economy and regulating
certain things are not regulating other
things and saying this is a monopoly and
this isn't robbing eye on esteem n't
really out of all of that stuff you
would see more competition you'd see
more competitive wages and the rest of
it so again I still would I still
believe this to be a government problem
their answer though is just ok well then
let's give it more government to make it
so that more people are equal all that
being said for the young person that
sees a bleak future that thinks okay
well how am I going to afford a house
what I think is you we should all right
now especially in the midst of Corona
and the riots and everything else
happening right now we should all really
be rethinking our lives if you are a
seventeen year old right now do you
really think that you should spend a
hundred thousand dollars going to
college when you can learn most of that
stuff probably in about six months on
YouTube now that there is still an
argument I think you can make that
College is a place for socialization and
it's good for young people to be away
from parents and and I think we can deal
with all of those issues in other ways
probably I have no doubt that we can but
we should all be reevaluated everything
we're doing you guys it's like we should
be re-evaluating do I want to work at an
office that I have to commute to and
drive in a car 45 minutes a day or spend
20 minutes in the tube can I work at
home is my home big enough so maybe I
need a bigger house now because I'm
gonna work from home do I want to live
in a big city that every few months is
gonna be ransacked by a bunch of jackals
I mean all of these things are up for
debate right now and I think if you have
your head on straight I think there's
incredible opportunity in the future so
I'm actually very bullish that we will
get out of this and get out of it well
but to bring it back to your earlier
question yes it's still gonna get worse
before then all right well we're gonna
wrap up in a cup
minutes but actually you talk about
reassessing in life one of the great
things for us doing the show is we do it
full-time now is something to become
it's awesome which is brilliant and and
what I was thinking about earlier
today's the the most precious thing I
think you can have in us in this society
that we have right now is being
unconsolable because once you get to
that that's when you can actually you
know you can say what you think you can
be free to have your opinions you don't
have to answer to anybody and you know I
want to thank you from both of us
because you and Joe Rogan have led the
way in allowing people like us to go oh
but that's possible you can do that you
can build something for yourself and you
don't have to be afraid of the people
around you you know Francis was joking
with you about comedy but he doesn't
need it anymore because of you because
us doing the show it's time to sing to
Nazis Dave thank you Mike wait a minute
I want to understand something so how if
you guys are now free and and somewhat
unkind syllable I tend to think you're
probably still more cancelable than you
think how are you guys generating most
of your read for the show right now so
you would be through through YouTube and
ads and revenue and then people
supporting us through patreon subscribe
to start PayPal etc now obviously
there's a level of cancellation that's
possible you know with all of those
things but I'm talking about more more
like you know getting fired or not being
booked for comedy clubs but yeah I mean
I can see where you're going yeah yeah
yeah so what you want to do is and if if
my example has helped you guys in any
way that's great so let my example light
the way a little bit further you the
next step for you guys is don't be so
reliant on YouTube don't be so certainly
on patreon patreon could boot you
tomorrow let's get you guys on locals I
mean nobody's gonna boot you and you'll
have a much more robust tech backing
than anything the patreon is going to
give you and I'm not saying that as a
salesman I'm saying that as purely if
you guys truly want to be independent
locals is not a giant platform what
locals is doing is building digital
homes we're a tech company
that gives you the tools to build
whatever it is you want but but in terms
of unconsolable it's it's it's ironic
because where did we start this
conversation with your your videos that
have been shadow banned which then of
course hurts your views and what happens
well now your views are hurt now your
monetization is very so you're not quite
out of the woods and by the way I'm not
quite out of the woods because there's
still other things that they can do to
get you but you see I think if you just
keep going in that direction and we're
working on a lot of really cool things
with locals right now on the
decentralization side and blockchain and
the rest of it it's see if you keep
moving in the direction to free yourself
you guys will free yourselves but you
ain't unn cancelable yet my nazi friends
all right
well you gave us the hard sell date but
actually we I think we applied some time
ago and we haven't heard back from
locals so please expedite we've been
overloaded but I'll write when we get
off here I'll make sure that they they
bump you up we have we've litters and
thousands of communities that are trying
to be created right now but it's a good
problem when you have too many people
trying to get on at once of course it is
but they thank you so much for coming on
keep please keep doing what you're doing
with big fans of yours and you know
people like you and people like us we're
making a positive difference in the
world and the more people are inspired
by your example the better we recommend
everybody gets the book don't burn this
book it is really really good I've got
to be honest I don't know why but you
know a lot of people have that same
sense with us sometimes where like they
come to watch our show and it's mainly
about the person we interview because
that's how we do it so when I was
reading your book I thought you would be
maybe kind of a rehashing of the stuff
that some of your guests have said or
whatever but it's really a fascinating
read and they'll look into your life and
the things that have inspired you to you
know to take a big risk and to create
something very special but they thank
you for coming on we've got one more
question for you and the question we
always end with is what's the one thing
we're not talking about there's a
society that we really should be well in
many ways I think I think we actually
just hit it which is that there is
opportunity coming I know it feels scary
I know people are freaking out I know
people every one of us is thinking wow
should I live where I live do I do I
need to protect myself in a different
way
you know even think a lockdown itself
it's like am I in am i trapped in a
house with a boyfriend or girlfriend or
husband or wife or roommate who I like
am i trapped in a house with someone I
hate like literally you know do I am I
too reliant on the systems that deliver
me food should I have a garden in the
back or should I have some well Dave I'm
sorry to interrupt but your recent
researches are so good you hit straight
up francis life story
[Laughter]
no I done died but uh but no carry on no
you should have some chickens ironically
we used to have chickens here and then
our dog was was elderly and had cancer
and we were spending so much time
focused on her we don't have the
chickens anymore which I would love to
have chickens right now because I'd be
getting eggs but putting that aside I
think I really believe this there's
incredible opportunity on the horizon
you know eking of Winston Churchill the
UK has had darker days than it's having
right now and it may seem scary and all
of that stuff but but leaders appear
good people stand up I think you guys
are doing your part you're not alone in
the UK you've got Douglas Murray who I
think is like the the best of the best
and we had him on the show like three or
four times now yeah yeah I mean I think
Douglas is basically the clearest
thinker we've got going right now you've
got you've got great people like Andrew
Doyle and you've got Maajid Nawaz and
and a slew of other people that are
fighting these battles alongside of you
guys and we will get through it and when
we get through it'd be one of the people
that that leads that blazes the trail to
the new world because there is a new
world on the horizon think about it this
way
February so four months ago basically
seems like an awful long time ago
remember when you could just go out with
your friends and you thought everything
was basically okay it feels like the
good old days already yeah oh well yeah
it was the good old days and those days
ain't coming back it doesn't mean we
won't reset to something but there is a
new world pretty much staring us in the
face right now and to loosely quote
Jordan Peterson if you can stand up
straight with your shoulders back and
you can clean your room you
might have a chance to profit from it
and I don't mean that purely monetarily
I mean that I mean that's spiritually
morally and societally as you always say
Dave what a great way to end the
interview thank you so much for coming
on guys take care we'll see you very
soon with another interview and a live
stream yeah take care guys and see you
soon thanks for watching guys as always
subscribe to the YouTube channel click
the bell button next to subscribe button
so you get notified when a video comes
out and follow us on all the social
media at trigger pot and also leave us a
nice review on iTunes and spread the
word